make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and a
lot of you guys have requested that I
make a video on astral regulator Thanos
specifically like the like a beyond
Omega level video and honestly I didn't
know who that like I don't know what
version of fan O's that was because if
I'm being honest with you guys I have
not really followed Jim starlings
infinity saga after the events of like
infinity crusade right like I finished
that and I was kind of like okay cool
I'm kind of done and that was that was
basically it I know he's written a lot
right like infinity siblings and and
infinity revelations and infinity of
relativity and all that I know he's done
all that and will go back and cover
those things because some of those
stories are cool others are not but I
think it'd be kind of cool to just sort
of have the whole infinity series on my
channel so we'll probably cover like
relativity your revelations or something
like that after this but you know I I
sat down and I was like okay what in the
heck is astral Regulator Thanos and I
looked it up and I was like okay so like
I have to cover this story because this
story's kind of nuts right now here's
the funny thing about it as I understand
it this is what the fan o swims story
was originally intended to be by jim
Starlin right he was the one who wanted
to write it that when Donnie Cates wrote
that story jim Starlin wanted to be the
one to create it because jim Starlin was
the one that did so much with the
character of fans and so the result of
this is that as we know Santos wins was
a story that was written you know by
Donnie Cates and so eventually Marvel
ended up releasing this and if I'm being
honest with you guys there's good things
about this story and things that I
wasn't really huge on but it was the
same thing with Thanos wins right there
were things that I loved about it things
I didn't really that I wasn't too big on
it I think if both of these stories were
combined it would be amazing it would be
absolutely ridiculously good because of
all the things that go down here right
for the way this kicks off is we
initially pick up with Thanos meeting
with Adam warlock now this comes hot off
the heels of Infinity Gauntlet is really
where this little segment of this story
comes from in the sense that those of
you guys who followed my series on
infinity garland and infinity war and if
you didn't you'll find both those down
in the description Infinity Gauntlet of
course as most of you guys know is a
story where Thanos discovered and then
started using the Infinity Gauntlet and
seize control of the universe and then
ultimately lost it to nebula an infinity
war or really the the aftermath kind of
a segue between the two so it was more
of a I guess like a prelude to as part
of warlock and the Infinity watch going
into infinity war itself The Living
Tribunal basically decreed that Adam
warlock had to disperse the stones right
the stones would no longer work in
unison the gauntlet itself wouldn't work
anymore
warlock had to basically find people who
were capable of wielding the stones but
not using them in order to keep them
protected by in order to make sure that
nobody could reassemble them together
again which seemed like a moot point
because even if they were a symbol
nobody could use them but people could
still use the the individual stones
hence the reason for the infinity watch
and so during that time we ended up
learning in infinity war that Thanos was
in possession of the reality stone and
we didn't initially know that we didn't
know who who warlock gave the reality
stone to but in this this little segment
here is his on to kind of fill in that
little bit of a gap because during
infinity war it was like and then Thanos
got the got the reality stone and that
was basically it and this is designed to
kind of fill in the gaps and essentially
say that the Thanos was the one who is
most suitable to wield it right because
only Thanos could really comprehend the
power of the reality stone and be able
to maintain that kind of discipline
right because with this stone in your
possession even your most subconscious
desires become reality you could fall
asleep and dream of like The Grudge and
then like she manifests because of the
reality stone and then kills you right
so like any number of those things could
happen if Thanos is really the only guy
who could maintain it and so what this
does is it picks up you know kind of
right now in the modern day and what it
does is it kind of gives us this idea
that Adam warlock feels as though
something's off in the universe right
something just not quite right there's
some kind of imminent danger coming now
this is part and parcel to the powers of
Adam warlock in the sense that he really
is very much a sort of you know Jesus s
character in Marvel right he dies and
he's reborn over and over and over again
he could never truly be killed he'll
always end up coming back in some form
of fashion at the same time he also kind
of has this cosmic awareness and through
his experience with the soul stone is
also sort of partly partial to the
universe now how deep reaching this goes
and exactly what this means on like a
definitive concrete level Jim Starla's
never really explained right it's almost
like the the white phoenix of the crown
and like her role in the multiverse why
she just fixes things that are broken
whatever in the hell that means and so
with Adam warlock a lot of it's kind of
the same way it's pretty ambiguous and
it really just sort of allows Marvel and
jim Starlin to kind of have a blank
slate in terms of what they want to do
with his character and and so on and so
forth but ultimately he ends up
basically travelling alongside pip the
troll to go see Thanos right this is a
really cool moment here because pip the
troll of course he's a long-standing
member of the Infinity watch a
long-standing friend of warlock the two
of them had been together for quite some
time but traveling and seeing fan OHS
was really one of the first acts of war
for a couple reasons right the first
thing is something seems off and Thanos
might know something but the other part
of this is the two of them have a very
lengthy relationship they've been on
again off again allies more so than that
there's a huge amount of respect between
the two and so as Adam warlock begins
talking to Thanos and saying like you
know there's some kind of dramatic
change that's coming there's a kind of
approaching darkness it's a cool moment
because Thanos kind of chimes in and
basically says yes you know there is a
kind of darkness approaching and he
kills Adam warlock he's like I am that
darkness and right off the bat Thanos
destroys Adam warlock
like literally incinerate his entire
body patrol teleports the hell out he's
like man this is wild piece and like
bails and then Thanos is just like take
the body and dispose of it done and so
like from there you pick up on the
planet Chandalar two weeks later Chandal
are of course being the home of the
Shiar empires with Adam warlock
basically re-emerging after this
two-week period then the question is
what in the heck is going on right like
why did Thanos kill me now Adam warlock
doesn't immediately suspect the Thanos
is of some kind of like terrible
horrible nefarious plot he believes he's
doing some pretty shady stuff but he
really wants to get more to the bottom
of things and to figure out what's
happening the problem with this is that
once pip the troll locates Thanos and
then teleports him and Adam warlock to
it Adam warlock gets blown up by a
missile he immediately gets destroyed by
a missile and the response of a nose is
like like when he's talking to his Black
Order it's like you know yes you know
Adam warlock will come back but all we
have to do is kill him three times after
that it won't matter and so what he ends
up doing is basically traveling to this
particular location this this particular
artifact looking for a kind of puzzle of
sorts and the reason why I really kind
of ties into infinity siblings and the
sense of what you had in that story is
you had a future version of Thanos that
basically ended up meeting with his
younger self and what does this future
version of Fanus is doing is basically
guiding younger Thanos to some kind of
end goal but he never actually told him
what the end goal was there was just you
have to do these things that were to get
to this point where I'm at and so that
O's isn't a lot of waste blindly
following the orders of his future self
under the idea that one he knows himself
so he trusts himself and two there's
gonna be some kind of grand payoff or
something along the way so the result of
this is that once Thanos basically
accesses this particular artifact and
learns of this kind of map of sorts you
know this particular location that it's
sending him to of course he gets back
aboard his ship and then ultimately we
end up picking up with Star Fox now star
fox or eros
is the brother of a lot of you guys
probably know that by now the two of
them have a very very lengthy history
infinity siblings really push that
history in that relationship to the
extreme but is one of these things worse
kind of like okay
eros has a couple a couple tools at his
disposal the first one is that he
basically utilized the time-traveling
technology of Kang the Conqueror and the
reason why was during the events of
infinity siblings King came to the
realization that somewhere along the
line Pharaoh's dies and when that
happens he ultimately ends up dragging
the entirety of the multiverse down with
the death of Thanos triggers a cascading
effect that brings everything to an end
prematurely so the idea was that Thanos
has to live and so came to conquer
basically orchestrated all these
different events to who to ensure that
right so kind of a spoiler for a video
that we're gonna cover later on but the
long and short of this is that eros
hidden stolen some of the technology of
of King in order to ensure that should
something happen where Thanos engaged in
some kind of nefarious plot that eros
can go back in time and correct it the
other part of this is that a device has
basically been created this exceedingly
small it is also based on the technology
of khang that can be used to essentially
track Thanos right because eros does not
have that inherent ability the next
thing that really happens here is a new
form of manifestation from Adam warlock
usually Adam warlocks body always kind
of enters the cocoon state and Adam
warlock comes back
what is up happening here is that some
guy ends up falling off a cliff and that
person is then suddenly in case in a
cocoon and then after a two-week period
Adam warlock re-emerges right so
basically this random being was Rima T
realized into Adam warlock and then Adam
warlock returned this is not normal it
doesn't usually happen and there is in
fact a force behind everything pulling
the strings when it comes to Adam walk
there's a reason why all this is
happening with him and so what it does
from here is it basically picks up with
with eros you know ultimately tracking
down phantoms and it's kind of this cool
little little moment here because
Pharaohs of course is looking for eros
under the guise that his future self
informed him that eros will become very
important with regards to the various
goals that they want to achieve and so
while Thanos cannot kill eros what he
has to do is essentially find him and
then keep him contained so that he can
be used at a future point in time what
that use is going to be and the role
that euros is going to play of course
we'll find out at some point you know
wound up finding out in this story but
you know from there of course eros
communicating with Isaac Isaac of course
being the computer of Titan the one that
basically kind of governs the whole
society
and so on ends up using this tracking
device puts it on to Thanos and then
makes himself intangible now the way it
is that eros does this is by
manipulating time and it's a little bit
of a weird thing when it comes to the
notion of phasing in and out of reality
technically speaking the way this works
is that Marvel kind of seems to adopt
this mentality of like things travel in
like one second chunks right so like if
you were one second ahead of me I
wouldn't be able to see you but if
you're a fraction of a second ahead of
me then it means that like you're kind
of this intangible being that I cannot
truly see but you kind of exist in that
same moment I mean because that that
fraction of time is so astronomically
small right so well if that really makes
any sense you know but it's it's one of
those one of those weird things right
like imagine the time it takes for you
to turn your head around and that's
really what this is equivalent to right
like it takes you you know if you if you
were to snap your head back you know it
would take you maybe like one-and-a-half
seconds to do but like in that one and a
half second period you've also got
exceedingly shorter amounts of time
fractions of a second and what Marvel's
doing here really what jim Starlin is
doing here is introducing this idea that
Eros his ability to manipulate time is
such that it's not putting him seconds
ahead of Thanos
is putting him fractions of a second
ahead of Thanos which means he's
essentially in the same moment that
Thanos is in but because he's kind of
out of phase meaning he's fractions of a
second ahead Thanos cannot really see
him right it's one of these weird things
right like how can you interact with
something that doesn't know you're there
when you're technically not there it's
weird and it's really finicky I
understand if you're totally baffled and
totally confused it's just one of those
plot points and Marvel traits in order
to achieve a certain goal and so what is
up happening here it was of course Adam
warlock and pip ended up tracking down
Thanos and once they arrived a nose has
already left the area but and of course
they end up arriving and meeting with
eros and this is a very welcome
ally given the history between these
characters the fact that eros has
consistently worked to thwart the
schemes of Thanos right so they're
allies in that regard and bringing to
bear this information that eros has put
a tracking device on Thanos in order to
locate him and he also has the ability
to manipulate time is a cool little
thing because it means it's basically
they're out if they choose or have the
opportunity to use it the other part of
this is that as they're talking Adam
warlock gets hit with a missile again it
just comes out of nowhere just hits him
and then Adam warlock is of course
destroyed right that's the end of that
now pip the troll ends up teleporting
away but basically it's one of these
things were Pippin and Indira's have
this conversation of hey like we have
our chance to basically combine
our information and to figure out what
this bigger picture is right it's kind
of like the Illuminati effect that using
their information that they become
greater than the sum of their parts and
so from there you end up seeing the
annals more or less being teleported
away and encountering his future self
now this future version of Thanos is
amazing looking right like he looks like
eternity with the face of mistress death
like I don't know it's kind of wild like
having him look this way it looks kind
of crazy but he looks like a cosmic
entity and so the question is how did
phantos achieve this level of power and
the way in which he gets to that point
is actually pretty solid because what
this does is it basically leads to
Thanos and his future self having this
conversation now his future self is
again pretty ambiguous here again it's
that conversation eros is going to be
important you can't kill him you have to
capture him you have to hold on to them
so on and so forth but you also have a
tracking device on you right so like
make sure you get rid of that so eros
cannot find you that kind of a thing
ultimately because the eros is aligned
with pip and because pip has the ability
to track Thanos no matter where he is
doesn't really matter at all but what we
end up having here is is basically
future Thanos and what passes for
present-day Thanos concluding their
conversation and then you end up having
eros and hip Patrol of course teleport
to Thanos his location and when they get
there this planet the planet zelphia I
think is what it is the last time eros
was here during the events of infinity
siblings the place was a very lush and
welcomed environment right he was
beautiful it was like a giant rainforest
very tropical and gorgeous something
seems to have happened here that laid
waste to the entire location and so when
the question is like have you teleported
us to the wrong place the response is no
like this entire place has basically
been totally annihilated or totally
destroyed and what you have here is that
this location has been transformed into
the realm of mistress death that's what
this is now right it's the realm of
death which is really kind of weird
because mistress death does not occupy a
physical plane she doesn't really exist
on any one particular physical planet
but you can't get on a spaceship and fly
to the realm of mistress death she
exists as an other dimensional entity
she literally exists in the afterlife
right so I mean I guess you could you
could get on a ship and fly to the
afterlife if the ship explodes you're
like flies into a star and die then sure
you can get to the half your life but
you can't physically go there I mean I
guess you can if you can manipulate
dimensional barriers like Doctor Strange
or somebody like that or like fan OHS
but what it does is it switches back
over to Thanos and him basically just
sort of sitting in space and we're
Corvus glaive and the outriders don't
really know why he's there they don't
really know what's going on like like
what they're waiting for
Thanos
response is I've been informed that at
this point there's gonna be an object or
a device passing through here and my job
is to take it and so it's kind of like
okay like we'll see how this goes which
is kind of wild and ultimately it ends
up being a comet that flies through
there now if a nose of course ends up
traveling to the comet by himself and
this is an interesting thing because
it's not just any regular comet the more
important thing to come out of this is
it that Oh States whatever this object
is and he basically says its power of a
magnitude exceeding that of the infinity
gems right so whatever this object is
it's way beyond the power of the
Infinity stone which really of course
interest a nose because he's always been
on a quest to attain absolute power the
problem with this is that the device
hidden inside the object hidden inside
this cut of this comet is not something
that can just be arbitrarily attained
right I mean you know it's not light you
know it was created and then just
dropped off on earth somewhere and like
it's just been sitting in a convenience
store it can't be one of those things
where just anybody can get their hands
on it
but there's all kinds of power
protecting it you know like this kind of
cosmic energy source and so Thanos of
course starts ripping it apart starts
pulling it away and in the process he
himself begins undergoing disintegration
his body starts breaking down the power
is really more than his physical form
can handle which really speaks volumes
to how much power we're talking about
here because the kind of energy that's
needed to physically damage Thanos is
astronomical really what happens here is
once he breaks through to the core of
this comet and he secures this object
for himself then what it appears to be
is this kind of orb of sorts now we'll
find out exactly what this is and what
is what is able to do but from there
famous when he kind of muses and asked
the question you know like I'm not
really even sure what this is for myself
of course his future version just kind
of seems to appear to Thanos and it says
it's both a promise and a mystery take
this thing and use it and I promise all
your questions will be answered and so
what it does is it leads to Thanos
showing up to the realm of mistress
death and of course as soon as he
arrives here danos is told you cannot be
here and that's the way it usually is
right Thanos has been banned from the
realm of mistress death for quite some
time he's not really welcome here and
the thing about him showing up is he's
really kind of musing and saying like
for all the people who tell me that I
cannot come here which of you is going
to stop me right how many times have I
come in here and mistress death says I
can't be here and then she sends some
force after me and then I totally
destroy it who's gonna stop me or you
guys gonna stop me and Thanos of course
annihilates all the Hinch men and the
various people that are there to prevent
him from stay
the realm of mistress death they're all
completely destroyed and then Thanos
begins speaking directly to death
herself and says how many times have you
spurned my advances how many times have
I made my affections known to you and
you've rejected me how many times does
that happen well nevertheless if I
cannot possess then I shall become and
using this object Thanos transfers the
energy into mistress death pulls her
into himself eradicate Smith's death
entirely and Thanos himself becomes the
new Death with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob fork
the guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a light and I will catch you all
later cliffhangers peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you